[Music]
moldova is a small country under
enormous geopolitical pressure
facing an influx of hundreds of
thousands of refugees from ukraine and
the fear it could be next on russia's
hit list
we are nowadays ukraine and ourselves
are on the border
between
russia and the west and we need the
support to to be able to maintain this
stability it's in everyone's interest
the country is teetering with economic
challenges and political divides that
are being exacerbated by the building
humanitarian crisis and the situation
could rapidly become critical without
more help soon
i don't even want to
consider that scenario it's
it's dire
there's fear in moldova that they may be
next after ukraine the country is not a
nato member and unlike ukraine it has a
very small military around 5 000 people
some here believe that putin will test
the west by trying moldova next
publicly officials insist that
everything is fine and there is rare
unity and messaging between the
opposition and the government who fear
triggering domestic unrest
russians have strategically destabilized
this country for the better part of
three decades there is also concerns
that any sign of instability here could
give the russians an excuse to invade to
create
and
resonate
for russians to interfere to save
russia's people in moldova there are
already russian troops on moldovan soil
in the rebel breakaway republic of
transnistria a self-declared country
that is not even recognized by russia
but heavily supported by it this is one
of the main factors of risk to moldovan
national security transnistria even has
its own military and it's the same size
as moldova's
intelligence analysts believe russian
troops could come back through
transnistria to attack odessa in ukraine
or moldova we tried to go to
transnistria to see what's happening
there but we were stopped at the border
so we just tried to cross over into
transnistria that was unsuccessful
they saw our cameras in the back
typically television crews not allowed
in and clearly we fell into that
category essentially what happened is we
pulled up they took our passports went
in they were gone for
uh
a while we're not sure what they were
doing at that point possibly trying to
search figure out who we are uh but we
do have a drone and we do have cameras
in the back and of course we also have
press id we don't
hide the fact that the journalists with
clearly the materials that we have on us
so they did not allow us to enter but it
was quite interesting because we were
able to see
people in their their transit history in
uniforms this is a breakaway republican
is not internationally recognized but
you can see
they're organized even though we didn't
get very far we did see evidence of the
russian peacekeeping troops stationed
there behind that green fence is a
russian armored personnel carrier
mercedes stephenson global news kicha
now